it's just expensive to breathe in 2024
between inflation the housing market
cost of living student loans all it you
can't sleep and you're snapping at your
kids everybody's anxious everybody wants
to stop the panic attacks everybody just
wants to go to sleep and I want to
propose something you may have never
considered before I think your body's
working perfectly the discomfort and the
anxiety you feel is your body's way of
getting your attention and letting you
know you're not safe if your credit
cards are maxed and you have no saving
if you did some napkin math and you're
going to be paying off your student
loans for the next 41 years or if you
can't afford to pay for a flat tire your
body would be failing you if it let you
rest and relax if it let you sleep if it
let you goof off with your friends or
have a deep connected intimate moment
with a romantic partner your body's just
doing its job the problem is we've
created a life and a financial reality
that our bodies were never designed to
live in